Wow we are up close and personal
no I mean like you've done oh no you
know your life is different now welcome
drag queens are the most amazing species
of human in my opinion I've tried to do
my own drag queen make up a couple times
on this channel in the past and it has
gone well and not well set that let's
keep this mediocre train going I tweeted
up asking you guys what sort of drag
queen look should I try to beat my face
into today and overwhelmingly so many of
you wanted me to beat my face into
Trixie Mattel who I love so much I'm
like out of breath because I'm so
excited about this her makeup is so
extreme it takes drag queen to this like
cartoon Barbie Dolly Parton weird level
that's so fun to see so I'm going to try
to make myself look like Trixie Mattel
which is so much easier said than done
more so than that I'm going to try to do
it without watching a tutorial
she has tutorials online of her makeup
looks and I'm not gonna do that I'm just
going to try and on top of that handicap
I'm only using drugstore makeup whoa so
one of the first images that came back
was from Buddha 9:6
and this event of Trixie Mattel is just
from this video so this is what I'm
going to try - I'm so sorry in advance
Trixie I'm so sorry
okay okay we're okay I'm going to use
this bandana to pull my hair back oh god
I don't even know how to start I'm going
to put a base layer of foundation on
let's make our canvas is blank and
monotone as possible this is like a
selfish video because I just wanted to
go buy a new makeup at the drugstore
this is l'oreal infallible total
coverage foundation okay let's just put
some foundation on oh shoot I brought
out a primer spray from NYX well thanks
for being here smeared on your face is a
biscuit and nuts foundation is that
gravy part with the I covergirl Katy
Perry kitty what I have this Katy Perry
for covergirl kitty whisper like white
eyeliner I'm gonna just start doing that
try to oh it already bent it doing it I
needed pencil sharpener oh well we're
gonna just start putting white in the
tops of her eyes and underneath where we
see the Trixie has done this sorry oh
okay here we go yeah I'm also trying to
do this like relatively quickly because
I or myself now we're gonna go
underneath this is a great base
basically we just covered the entire
area that indicates we did not sleep
well last night
Oh for a thousand years and keeping with
the theme of all of us being drugstore
purchased products
I'm trying stay within that theme I have
this Bronx colors contouring palette
that's got like this white and bronze
colors isn't available at drugstores but
it's the same kind of like price range
as drugstore we're gonna take a dirty
eyeshadow brush and just blot it on a
makeup way and then clean it on the palm
of her hand because we are just a
scumbag and then we're gonna take this
white contouring shadow
oh let's see how this sets this
illuminating
wow this powder also has an essence of
iridescent which should be the name of
an R&B group essence of iridescent not
totally matte okay so it's a bunch of
like shades of brown that go up shaded
up into her eyebrows so this is Revlon's
Colorstay Oh which is Gwen Stefani is
doing a whole line with Revlon right now
and this is part of her line look how
very Gwen Stefani she's just a girl in
the world so I'm gonna use this brown
powder in here take a brush that we're
gonna clean on a makeup way try it on
their palm we just went like outline
that goes into our nose we can blend
this out don't worry oh look at that
this side of my nose is like new year
new me and this side is like what your
is it cinch that no I'm going to take a
fluffier brush and sort of blend it out
a little bit I'm just gonna put some
more brown powder just sort of in the
socket and take some of these neutral
like yellows and tans and sort of blend
that into the Browns you're just to
soften it that's okay
we're gonna go back in with the this
angled brush and our dark brown and
we're going to make sure that there's a
real delineation between the white and
the brown i have eyebrows stuff on my
eyebrows from earlier today I'm gonna
wipe that off with the makeup okay now
we're gonna put some white top white
goes lower brow bone that looks like a
thing forties eyebrows go above and
beyond don't want to try to Matt out
like this part of my eyebrow with
foundation and then just like draw in
more exaggerated eyebrows oh also I
should use this white on duh okay let's
go oh this looks great base we use a
covergirl eyebrow filler thing you have
to fade the eyebrows into oh oh that's
perfect mm-hmm oh how flattering want to
look like you got electrocuted but only
in the eyebrows the worst part about
doing your eyebrows one is the fact that
you're bad at it and then to try and
repeat it on the other side I'm gonna
brush this with an eyebrow brush
well that's insanely terrible how did
this get this bad
so much worse there's a phrase quit
while you're ahead but when you don't
feel like you're ahead you don't need to
quit hold on I'm gonna really try to fix
this okay that feels a little better to
me I'm gonna put some powder on see what
that does
you know I can't okay
eyebrows are good enough for now oh this
has been a journey we're gonna start
what are we gonna do now we have the big
swooping black eyeliner I have just
covergirl liquid liner that I don't know
what it's called cuz I got rid of the
packaging it looks like the shape of
like a Siamese cat and a Disney movie
we're gonna try our best to do this
insanely exaggerated winged eyeliner and
see what happens why my TV turn on
there's a ghost that once watch Bravo so
bad again my eyebrows aren't oh it's
creased God dang it
wow wow wow these profiles are very
different but both of them say are you
okay okay we have our eyeliner and I
feel like David Blin just held his
breath underwater for like 12 minutes
for no real reason we're gonna clean it
up a little bit okay eyes are sort of
sort of a thing now we're gonna work on
this like so bronze and pinky cheek with
like the cut-in of highlights I had this
true blend contour palette from
covergirl this is a cream I'm gonna use
this dirty dirty makeup sponge good
these insane cheeks just like a Nike
swoosh of color
we need some pink in there I didn't buy
a blush and the blush that she has in
this photo looks a little pinky purpley
so I'm just gonna use this eyeshadow
palette that looks like we're almost
having an allergic reaction to something
perfect and then we want that real deep
cut line so I'm gonna take my Maybelline
concealer in white and just cut through
the cheeks we're getting there lashes
lashes are a big deal we got lashes on
top and this exaggerated lash on the
bottom and I did something kind of crazy
I bought these magnetic lashes from
ardell at Rite Aid where you basically
put your top tier on and then you put
your bottom lashes on and then connect
to each other via magnet so you don't
use lash glue I think it's witchcraft so
we're gonna test it out right now upper
lashes lower lashes we put this one
under our top lash oh god this feels
weird is mother [ __ ] great why I'm gonna
get other lashes and just glue them on
my face hold on I think these are
Adele's black 33 I look like I'm Marge
Simpson with the makeup gun right
they're on they're on they're on we'll
curl them in a second oh I put them on
the wrong eyelid that's why God think
it's not too bad this all looks normal
and fun angry I actually really am proud
of myself
jacksy has this very signature like half
lash that goes underneath and I don't
have any other lashes that aren't in
magnetic but I have these individual
ones and I'm gonna try and glue on and
see what the Chabot
okay this is obviously not good the last
piece that we have to add to this puddle
right now puddle giant pink Barbie doll
lips so we bought purple lip liner this
is Revlon's Colorstay lip liner in
violet rush and we're gonna overdrawn
our lips and see what happened oh look
at that
okay oh no she is much more of a pink
lip by these red ones color charts lip
powders from the Gwen Stefani line I
guess they're like eye shadows upon your
lips let's try it adding some machine Oh
put on she's wearing a headband so I
think maybe if I put my headband on
correctly it'll obviously bring a look
together oh there we go
Wow perfect what an identical match oh
my god was it weird as I think that I
look like the lovechild of Katya and
Trixie Mattel right now okay well there
you go there's another video of me
trying an iconic drag queen look it can
a just ruining the foundation of the
artistry that this drag queen has built
for themselves
I'm so sorry Trixie I really tried I
mean I don't think it's that bad I just
don't like looking at my own face if you
liked this video give a thumbs up and if
you want me to attempt other iconic drag
looks please leave them in the comments
down below and do not forget for the
sake of everything that is right and
wrong about this look to subscribe to my
youtube channel rivets moment in time
I'm making videos every Tuesday and
Thursday so click that Bell notification
and the subscription link so that you
are notified when these videos of such
art to go live the viewfinder I think is
giving this look more justice than what
I'm looking at in this mirror down below
because what I'm looking at this mirror
down below is just so bad and sad and
wrong and not it just is so bad
I'm sorry Trixie